i am very interested friends
in trance states i am very interested
in the immersive
trance
the immersive trance is
one which leaves nothing to the
imagination the immersive trance is like
nothing you can imagine the immersive
trans takes no prisoners the immersive
trans
is
when you are completely subsumed when
you are completely
absorbed it's a mystical state
the immersive the immersive trance
requires obliteration the immersive
trance is obliteration obliteration of
what obliteration of
the self obliteration of identity
obliteration of time obliteration of
space you are
imagination you are pure awareness in
the immersive trance you become
narrative and living mythology in the
immersive trance you are that
national geographic documentary in the
immersive trance you are exploring the
coral reef in the immersive trans you
are looking for buried treasure in the
immersive trance
you find the pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow in the immersive trance you
unleash the three brave reckless god
that lives inside of you the immersive
trance is pure unadulterated awe the
immersive trance is accompanied by a
sense of first sight unencumbered by
knowing this the immersive trance is
about virginal noticing it's about
heightened qualitative intensity and
it's about
a feeling of revelation of revealed
truth
now there's a guy called otto rank who
wrote about the idea of the holy and
when talking about religious experiences
that accompany these trance states these
religious experiences these flashes of
revelation these mystical states these
trans states they are non-ordinary
states of consciousness in which our
sense of bounded identity falls away and
we enter into communion with
everything with godhead and religious
scholars have tried their best to find
the words to map these territories a
kind of cartography of us of ecstatic
states
and
there's a term called
the mysterium tremendous fascinosum
which means the mystery
that repels and the mystery that
attracts because when you are in these
borderless realms and when you are in
communion and when you are paying
visitation to these non-ordinary states
of ecstatic surrender
and and and just cheer obliterating
obliterating astonishment obliterating
enthusiasm obliterating exuberance
obliterating bewilderment there is
ecstasy to be found there the freedom
from the self is experienced as
liberation no mind is freedom
freedom in in the sense of just ultimate
and and totalizing expansion
totalizing wonder
totalize
ejaculations of amazement you become
what you behold as mckenna said
and i live for these states of expansion
because i think they are curative and
they dissolve the cumulative build up of
stressors from ordinary life the over
identification with a self that is a
contracted contracted and constricted
self that metastasizes the ego that
becomes a tyrant the diseases of despair
that accompany the ego that becomes a
tyrant
are finally
shaken off in quaking annihilating glory
baseline
over egoic reality dissolves it's
pixelated and
replaced immediately with a kind of
ecstatic truth or poetic truth that
exceeds the literal grid it's the
never-ending story it's the goonies it's
the hunt for buried treasure it's the
mystery that repels and the mystery that
attracts all at once i am in the
presence of something grand something
can measure it to my capacity for wonder
this is it
this is the this is the secret
you know this is the philosophers and
wise men and teachers this is what they
understood this is the shamanic dance
and the waterfall this is how magic is
done
you hurl yourself into the abyss you
cast the self aside
and you realize
that it's a featherbed
glistening effervescent
oceanic
featherbed